hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so in this video i would
like to make a big update on gamestop i
didn't make an update on gme for some
time not because i don't believe in it
anymore i still do but just because
nothing much was happening so let's have
a look today at the chart and see what
is the situation let's get into it
[Music]
so here we go jamie i'm gonna start on
the daily time frame
and i want to hear just
make a recap of the situation with
with a step back so everything started
in april 20. we did the first wave then
we corrected for between april and of
april and august so roughly three four
months early august and of april the
three months and then we had this
massive surd wave as usual third waves
are very impulsive and in this third
wave it was the fifth wave that was
extended and that went to absolutely
crazy levels that are not respecting fib
extensions at all as you can see him if
i measure one plus three applied to the
bottom of the fourth you can see that
the 1.600 level got a reaction just
below and we had this consolidation and
then we squeezed and we went to crazy
levels
so what can we say first thing when we
look at the charts it's undeniable that
this is very bullish for the simple
reason that we're making higher lows all
the time
we have here this force corrective wave
that
is not easy to count using alienwave
theory
because this is quite messy it's a false
wave so it can be a zigzag a flat or a
triangle i only see here a triangle it
can also be a combination of zigzag flat
and triangle of course but here i see a
massive triangle so a b c d e the e wave
is bottoming here but let's say i don't
say this is what is going to happen but
even if we go slightly below coming back
to the 160 area we would still be
bullish the e-wave would just be a bit
lower i'm saying that just to show you
guys that it's a long term process it
might last i don't know maybe one two
three more months you can see we need to
break this trend line so right now the
signal for the fifth wave would be given
by a breakout of this trend line around
the 250 level once again what is good
about those chain lands is that they go
lower so if just time passed by
we would arrive on this trend line
staying at the same level in jan alright
so let's see but something needs to
happen before gen 22 for sure
i'm seeing here that i wanted to show
you guys we have a bullish hidden
divergence so those are not that easy to
spot because i am less used to spot it
compared to the regular bearish
divergence that i see right away because
my eye is used to that those hidden
because they are less easy to spot so
let me remind you how it looks
so
it's this one
so basically the market is making new
higher lows in a bearish environment
that is showed by the momentum so the
momentum is making new laws so it should
be a bearish development and still the
market manages to make higher lows here
price action momentum i use the macd you
can use rsi so as you can see what we
have here between
march 21
and august 21 the macd is going lower
i'm pretty sure the rsi does go lower as
well and so this is giving us a bullish
hidden divergence which is good news
which suggests that there's going to be
a consummation move but once again i
personally
keep an eye on those divergences but i
will not use it as a trading signal i
will combine it with a breakout so once
again which breakout the breakout of the
pattern we are analyzing where we have
the divergence so it can only be major
trend line that i see coming from 10 21
highs and going through june 21 high
so
once again the level would be 250 so
what we are looking for i don't know if
it's gonna happen right away but it's
something like this okay then if we zoom
in a little bit let's analyze this move
so
in discounting the force wave is
complete which makes sense when we look
at amc as well once again those two are
usually move together so amc is already
in the fifth wave so i expect the false
wave of gamestop to be finished here and
to be in the fifth one as well but we
have only completed the first wave of
the fifths
now we are doing a second wave so once
again second waves guys it cannot be a
triangle so it's a flat or a zigzag so
here i'm not sure what we're doing guys
i'm not sure if this is a flat that is
on the way
or is it a zigzag okay if it's a zigzag
it will go a little bit lower maybe to
the 165 area once again i don't think
this is what's gonna happen this week
i'm just saying that if we go there this
is totally fine for the long term
bullish scenario
and let's zoom in a little bit more and
see where are our support levels so the
major support is 178
and i use this trend line as well that
is for me the end of the force wave uh
signaling the end of the force
no sorry then of the force is here so
it's just a shorter term breakout that
is signaling that maybe you know we are
in the fifth
so
i'm monitoring this trend land and it
can be retested as you guys know it's
usually retested by the way it has been
retested already once so most likely we
won't be retesting it but even if we do
it's totally fine so
another breakout we can monitor is this
one but it's quite far you know if we
can have something like this this would
look good as well
so this is my take for gamestop targets
are still unchanged guys as you know i'm
giving you targets using feed
projections that are working whenever we
have a normal market development so not
like we had in the third wave for
example but i'm gonna assume we're gonna
have a normal market development even if
there are many reasons we don't and we
would go to the 800 level roughly once
again if we have a squeeze you guys know
that it can be a multiple of this so it
can go much higher like 2000 3000 area
maybe
let's have a look at the synthetic short
interest all right
i was checking naked
but let's have a look at jimmy
so the maximum synthetic shot is 13
right now we have three percent so we
have 10 percent more to come on the
upside which is the gamma let's see
where it is coming from
so once again the 950 is the biggest one
guys we have a
totally insane number of shares uh
around 75 million shares so this is very
very big and this is what's going to
create the bullish momentum once again
if we start to move higher if we check
on the short term what do we have
first of october we don't have much
here we have a little bit on the 300
strike october 15th but it's
5 000 it's not that big
so we have those
strikes but they are much higher as you
can see we don't have that before 300.
so once again the gamma is only going to
kick in if we start to approach 300
so we need to move higher first we need
to have the breakout here and only this
breakout would create this bullish
momentum that we are waiting for and
once again that's why i expect here a
third wave that might go i don't know
maybe to the 350 area but the third wave
needs to break this trend line to break
the 250 level go higher then we probably
have a pullback and then we would make
the fifth wave so let's see how things
happen but this is still looking very
good to me so that's it for today i hope
you guys enjoyed this video and if you
did please don't forget to click on the
sub like and bell button so you're gonna
be the first to know when i upload
anything new and stay close to shore i
see you guys